[Music]
there's so many new beauty releases
happening all the time so we gathered
some of the most hyped products from
april to test for ourselves we have two
new face products from one size beauty
the cheap clapper 3d blush trio palette
and the made for shade bronze and sculpt
trio let's get into the sculpt palette
first i used a mix of the bottom two
shades and they brought some much needed
warmth to my face they blend really
nicely and smoothly these are nice
bronzers but i think the real star of
the show here is the blush palette like
if i had to pick one of these two
palettes to splurge on it would
definitely be this one these are three
different formulas a flex cream a full
impact matte and a hyper sheen i went in
with a very light hand because these are
really pigmented and they just look
really beautiful and smooth on the skin
the color can be built up or toned down
as much as you want which i think is my
favorite thing about this palette there
are just so many different ways you can
use it and all the formulas work so
nicely together rare beauty just
released the positive light tinted
moisturizer with spf 20. i was so happy
that this had spf in it the formula felt
thicker and looked more full coverage
than i expected also this was a shade or
two too light for me so ignore that it
does sheer out as you apply it so it
looks less like a foundation and more
like a tinted moisturizer i applied the
rest of my powder makeup on top and
honestly wasn't loving how it looked i
felt like it kept building up in the dry
patches around my nose and just looked a
little too textured
but then i redid my makeup with all
cream products on top of this tinted
moisturizer and it looked so much better
just super dewy and fresh so i much
prefer using it with cream products this
is the nyx wonder stick cream blush
contour and it's literally a blush stick
that you use to contour your face
there's a lighter shade that's meant to
be used as a blush and a deeper shade
that you contour with i have never
contoured with blush so i was really
intrigued by this i applied the darker
shade wherever i would normally contour
and the lighter shade above it and then
blended it out
this isn't the easiest formula to blend
but i eventually got it looking pretty
good i didn't hate the blush contour
look i just think this blush formula
isn't great and i've definitely tried
better at the drugstore i haven't
experimented much with correctors but i
saw a tic toc recommending this one the
benefit boeing bright on brightening
under eye concealer
it has this peachy color to counteract
the darkness underneath the eyes i
tested it out before applying makeup and
i could see a difference already so then
i applied a small amount blended that
then applied concealer on top and i
think it did make a difference my under
eyes looked brighter than usual i
definitely noticed less darkness than
when i just used concealer and the
product didn't do anything weird to the
concealer i applied on top
it didn't make it patchy or bunch up so
i'm actually really into this i realized
later you're just supposed to wear this
on its own which i clearly did not do
but i was still happy with the results
charlotte tilbury came out with a new
pillow talk collection inspired by its
popular lipstick in pillow talk so i
picked up a few of the products i
already love the beauty light one so i
knew that i would love this pillow talk
shade it's super glowy and makes the
skin look so beautiful the multi-glow
highlighter was a new product for me the
packaging is so pretty i didn't even
want to touch it but i did it has this
almost soft blurring effect that looks
really nice and it's not glittery at all
just like a soft glow the product i was
most excited to try was actually the
mascara in the shade dream pop it's
described as a berry brown shade i don't
think i've ever tried a colored mascara
before but i applied it like i normally
would and i actually love the color the
formula isn't my favorite and neither is
the brush but i think the color was
actually flattering on my eyes it's
supposed to bring out the amber in brown
eyes i don't know if that's what's
happening but it did make my eyes look
really sparkly which i love i saw that
flower beauty had this spotlight liquid
highlighter that looked a lot like the
charlotte tilbury light wand in the
pillow talk shade so i really wanted to
compare the two to see if it was a dupe
the shades aren't exactly the same but
they're super close both are so easy to
blend out and look more natural and dewy
on the skin than a powder highlight does
i think the charlotte tilbury one is a
bit more reflective than the flower
beauty one but the effect is definitely
similar the flower beauty one looks just
as beautiful on the skin and it's almost
30 dollars cheaper so i highly recommend
this if you haven't gotten a chance to
try the light ones i'm an east coast
girl so i was so excited when i saw that
elf collab with duncan this was such a
fun cute idea this huge donut sponge was
so ridiculous i had to try it out it's
big even before wedding and it was
pretty hard at first but it doubled in
size once i wet it and it became a lot
softer and squishier i'm not gonna lie
applying foundation with this is kind of
great because it's so big it literally
applies foundation in five seconds
i decided to use it to apply all my
other makeup and the size does get more
difficult to work with the more precise
you're trying to be you can see that i
was accidentally spreading my blush up
way too high but i think overall the
makeup came out looking good obviously
this is more like a novelty than a super
useful makeup tool but it comes in handy
if you want to apply makeup quickly i
also ordered the glaze for days lip
gloss set because i cannot resist an
orange gloss let alone an orange gloss
that smells like glazed donuts this is a
really nice gloss the color is pretty
sheer but for the price point i think
this formula is super glossy and
comfortable on the lips
[Music]